MORE ON TODAY'S ARREST WITH
THE PANEL IN A BIT.
IN OTHER NEWS, THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION IS EXTENDING
AN INVITE TO RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN TO
VISIT THE U.S. EARLY NEXT
YEAR.
BUT, AFTER WHAT MANY SAW AS
DISASTROUS -- A DISASTROUS
SUMMIT BETWEEN PUTIN AND
TRUMP.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IN JULY AND
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES
CONFIDENCE THAT RUSSIA DID
MEDDLE IN THE 2016
ELECTIONS, SOME IN BOTH
PARTIES ARE NOW WONDERING
ALLOWED IF THAT INVITE IS A
GOOD IDEA.
STATE DEPARTMENT
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON HAS
OUR STORY.
>> RUSSIAN PRESIDENT
VLADIMIR PUTIN MAY SOON
RETURN TO THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> WE HAVE INVITED PRESIDENT
PUTIN TO WASHINGTON AFTER
THE FIRST OF THE YEAR FOR
BASICALLY A FULL DAY OF
CONSULTATION.
>> TRAVELING IN THE FORMER
SOVIET STATE OF GEORGIA,
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISOR
JOHN BOLTON SAYS OFFICIALS
ARE STILL DISCUSSING THE
SCHEDULE.
RUSSIAN STATE MEDIA SAY
SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO AND RUSSIAN FOREIGN
MINISTER SERGEY LAVROV SPOKE
TODAY TO PREPARE FOR
MEETINGS BETWEEN THE TWO
PRESIDENTS.
IF PRESIDENT PUTIN ACCEPTS
THE INVITATION, IT WOULD BE
HIS FIRST TRIP TO THE WHITE
HOUSE SINCE SEPTEMBER 2005.
PRESIDENTS TRUMP AND PUTIN
LAST MET AT A JULY SUMMIT IN
HELSINKI.
WITH A PRESS CONFERENCE
WHERE PRESIDENT TRUMP
DISCUSSED RUSSIA'S
INTERFERENCE IN THE 2016
U.S. ELECTION.
>> I HAVE PRESIDENT PUTIN.
HE JUST SAID IT'S NOT
RUSSIA.
I WILL SAY, THIS I DON'T SEE
ANY REASON WHY IT WOULD BE.
>> THAT BROUGHT WIDESPREAD
CRITICISM, EVEN AMONG SENIOR
CONGRESSIONAL REPUBLICANS.
>> EVERYONE WHO HAS DEALT
WITH PUTIN UNDERSTANDS FULLY
THAT THE BEST WAY TO DEAL
WITH HIM IS THROUGH STRENGTH
AND I JUST FELT LIKE THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS MADE US
LOOK AS A NATION MORE LIKE A
PUSHOVER.
>> BOLTON ALSO SAID THE
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
MAINTAIN DISCUSSIONS WITH
THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT ON
STRATEGIC STABILITY,
DISARMAMENT, AND REGIONAL
CONFLICTS.
>> FIRST, THE PRESIDENT MAY
BRIEFLY MEET AGAIN WITH
PUTIN NEXT MONTH IN PARIS.
WHILE THE TWO ARE THERE FOR